now i've warned you countless times that
democrats in new york
are giving us a precursor of what will
happen nationally if biden wins
now the most recent example comes from
leticia james the most left-wing
attorney general in new york state
history
today with great fanfare and a full pr
operation she announced that she wasn't
just investigating the nra
she intended to dissolve it all together
there are 18 causes of action improper
wage reporting
improper income tax withholding
failure to make required excise tax
reporting
and payments for these years of fraud
and misconduct
[Music]
we are seeking an order
to dissolve the nra in its entirety
and nominated for best actress in an
ongoing drama is well
first thing you need to know uh this has
zero connection to some of the internal
issues the nra has had in management
operations over the past few years has
nothing to do with that
and it reminds me of how they targeted
eric trump's foundation remember that
that raised like millions and millions
of dollars for st
jude's it was totally political now if
ms
james was really an unbiased official
looking to stem abuse in a
501c3 organization then why isn't she
launching an investigation into the
butchers of planned parenthood that prey
on women in the inner city
i can tell you why planned parenthood
has pledged
45 million dollars to elect democrats
this year
while the nra well a big nothing
well if she really cared about rooting
out corruption and fraud and waste
she has plenty of room to run in new
york politics i mean
come on man as bine would say the former
top democrat in new york state
new york state house was just given
prison time for corruption
who was once one of the most powerful
politicians in new york state political
history
comes to grips with his fate sentenced
to 78 months in prison and a million
dollar fine
for profiting off his office as assembly
speaker
now maybe she should find out the real
reason governor cuomo abruptly disbanded
his anti-corruption task force i believe
with the credibility of this commission
you can go a long way
towards restoring that public trust that
25 member panel was supposed to spend 18
months rooting out political corruption
in new york state
but cuomo shut down the commission in
march the new york times reported last
week that cuomo's top aides repeatedly
blocked anti-corruption investigators
yeah nothing to see there at all
now and don't forget this smart
aggressive lawyers can always come up
with some rationale to sue or
investigate
you or frankly any organization they
have armies of lawyers
paid for in this case by the taxpayers
and they can devote countless hours
to drive up your litigation fees that's
how this racket works
and even if they have a lame case
they can still beat you by bankrupting
you
and that's her goal the new york state
attorney general
and that's her goal with the nra one
doesn't
need too active in imagination though to
see
how this sort of strategy could play out
nationally in a biden administration
now in that case the doj will be stacked
with prosecutors like ms
james who needs to debate issues on the
merits about
guns or gun ownership when you you just
can take out the opposition
take them out of the game altogether
they'll go after pro-life groups
conservative think tanks conservative
radio shows
cable networks even churches
like efforts to defund the police or
tear down historical monuments this move
against the nra
it's a test run for broader efforts to
frighten and intimidate people
for exercising their god-given rights
now these
these are malicious marxists and they've
had a lot of practice doing this
remember they've been borrowed into our
schools and our universities for
years they've been protected by teachers
unions and
compliant administrators the angle has
warned you
over and over again that they're not
content to keep this on campus though
or in civil you know certain liberal
cities and enclaves
like a nasty pathogen it needs more
hosts it needs to go national
and they'll have the doj to sue you the
epa
to monitor you and the irs to audit you
they'll have unlimited resources and
plenty of left-wing judges on
state and even federal courts on their
side
they'll defund the police and they'll
disarm the public
hell yes we're going to take your ar-15
your ak-47
you're going to take care of the gun
problem with me you're going to be the
one who leads this effort
i'm counting on you so to to gun owners
out there who
say well obama administration means
they're going to come for my guns
bingo you're right oh my god
now throughout this tumultuous year of
the pandemic and the riots
democrats implicit promise to the
country
is the following if you help us defeat
trump put biden in office
things are just going to calm down
they'll go back to you know basically
normal
but as usual with frauds that's a lie a
biden presidency will
cater to a coalition of radical
interests of the leticia james
variety that means a campaign of revenge
on traditional america
just like new york is waging now on the
nra
and the only way to end the far left
cycle of retribution and silencing
is to beat him at the ballot box and
badly
now right now if you don't like the way
like de blasio's running new york city
and you're living in new york or the way
lori lightfoot is running chicago and
you live in chicago well you can pick up
and move
but think about this under abide
administration there'll be no escape
from politically motivated
investigations
and your basic first second hell all of
your constitutional rights they're all
going to be in jeopardy
your liberties will only be protected
and protected from these radical
america-hating monsters
if voters this november punish the
democrats
and they make them pay for coming after
our prosperity
and yes our guns i want to say those
fighting words
for everyone within the sound of my
voice to hear
and to heed and especially
for you mr core
from my cold dead hands
that that never gets old now can you
imagine
if a red state a.g decided to go after
the aclu with the sole purpose
of destroying the entire organization
the media would go
absolutely bonkers an attorney general
who cares
about the well-being of his or her state
what would that attorney general be
doing that be focusing on prosecuting
the criminals
and the organized mobs running wild in
places like new york city
the thugs there are so brazen they're
attacking innocent people running
bodegas and
police officers who are just out doing
their jobs
things are so bad in new york the
governor
is begging rich people to return
hey you got to come back when are you
coming back
we'll go to dinner i buy a drink
come over i'll cook
yeah that'll work
do ms james and governor cuomo think
that the thousands of people
who are now listing their apartments for
sale or rent
are doing so because the nra has too
much power in the state
what a phony diversion the fact is
none of these new york officials just
like none in the biden camp
have a clue about how to make your life
better
all they have to offer is more economic
ruin
more crime and endless charges of
systemic racism
and this just goes to show you that the
hope and change slogan of obama's was it
looked cool on a poster right
but it was always a lie apparently he
and
biden they didn't change america at all
in fact after they finished their eight
years
the country elected trump so by their
logic the country has gotten even worse
so for the next four years they intend
to put anyone
who does not submit to their rule in
detention
you're going to have less control over
every aspect of your life
while the connected woke crowd
will have the power to do whatever it
wants remember
rules for thee but not for me
it's time for the silent majority to be
silent no more
there are more of you than you think we
don't have to live like this
in fear that our neighbors will report
us for not wearing a mask on our own
front lawn
or in fear that if we're defending our
homes and our families they'll make us
the criminals
or in fear that our religious beliefs
put targets on our backs
or in fear that the government will
investigate us just because we oppose
certain policies
think of what the fbi led by jim comey
did to president
trump and candidate trump they tried to
cancel his entire presidency
do not let them do this to america
and that's the angle